I believe the deputies reacted did the
best that they could and I don't believe
it was excessive force what happened to
Michael was he was beaten and beaten to
death that's what happened to Michael
[Music]
in October 2007 an officer from the
Orange County California Sheriff's
Department knocked on fredrik glasses
door and told him his son had died in a
jail altercation it was devastating and
I didn't know whether to do this scream
or cry or what to do and I asked him how
that had happened and he said there was
some sort of confrontation I said what
do you mean by a confrontation Michael
Patrick glass was living on the streets
of Santa Ana when police stopped him for
having an open container at the time of
his arrest he was schizophrenic bipolar
had a history of seizures and was an
alcoholic after the officer figured out
he had a similar ticket he hadn't
appeared on in court
Michael was taken to jail after pleading
guilty a judge sentenced him to five
days the day Michael would have been
able to leave he felt ill one of these
cellmates said he was acting funny
the cellmate reported to one of the
deputies and the deputy asked him what
his problem was he needs to yes he said
he would like to see medical for some
medical attention
the deputy ordered him out of this cell
and told him to stand up against the
wall
the deputy came out of his little
station not behind him and ordered
Michael to walk back towards him while
well as he walked backwards towards the
deputy he will look like this over his
shoulder and supposedly that's a big
no-no they look back to see where you're
walking backwards to the deputy grabbed
him and threw a monthly cell floor he
wasn't fighting or anything and he was
already in a contained area locked in a
contained area immediately there was a
second deputy there a third deputy a
fourth a fifth and on and on it went
until there's so many deputies you
couldn't count how many deputies were
there a handheld video from the Orange
County Jail begins after the officers
surround Michael
he was stunned nine times with a Taser
that that's document at nine times I can
remember view in the film and at one
point in time while they are beating him
Michael tells them you're killing me
literally you're killing me
the amount of force used to control this
individual that was excessive in my eyes
thomas ab d f-- was the attorney for
Frederick glass and is a former Orange
County police officer an investigator of
twenty years and this is not a situation
in which Michael was just be it was
killed beaten to death with mr. Abdi's
help Frederick last sued the County of
Orange as well as six deputies involved
with the incident there was no evidence
that he was a violent individual didn't
cause any problem in the courthouse that
caused any problem in transportation to
the courthouse during the trial the
lawyer for the county and deputies
Norman Watkins argued that Michael was
violently resisting Michael was not
resisting he was not fighting with them
here there was passively resistance in
other words he just refused to let them
[Applause]
in addition to being shocked with a
Taser nine times the autopsy
commissioned by the county and performed
in a neighboring County indicated
multiple blunt impact injuries to the
body involving the head neck torso and
extremities
I believe the deputies reacted that the
best that they could and I don't believe
it was excessive force
Michael Krueger is the current captain
of the jail where the incident occurred
although he wasn't in charge in 2007 he
agreed to review the case for us there's
a little more than just passive
resistance I think the deputies made a
strong attempt to get his hand and we're
trying to pull them
out from underneath him the ratio
between deputies and deputy or staff and
inmates is much higher on the inmates
side when we have disturbances or we
have incidences of any kind they become
very critical very quickly and so it's
very important to make sure we have the
appropriate response we tried to get him
under control the deputies on scene
tried to get him under control and
that's when he started acting very
bizarre and an incredible amount of
strength kept resisting with them and
just would not calm down no deputy ever
said that they had a cut a bruise a
scratch anything from Michael Michael
had 54 separate contusions on his body
and he was tased nine times it's just
not normal for to do that in protective
custody we certainly believe that
situations like this are avoidable
Hector V Agra is the executive director
of the American Civil Liberties Union of
Southern California you should be able
to expect that your bodily integrity
will be respected in jail that you won't
have force applied to you if it's not
necessary that if you're complying with
the rules of the jail that you won't be
struck that you won't be tasered here
you had a situation with an individual
who was in jail for drunkenness it was a
five day stay and it ended in his death
and I think we all have to be concerned
with a situation that you know very
little can escalate into a death it
often escalates because of over
incarceration of jails with people have
committed small crimes like Michael's
here in the in the case of Michael last
part of the defense of the county was
that deputies are vastly outnumbered in
the jails and so they have to be able to
respond quickly and severely to ensure
compliance and it's that sort of
hair-trigger mentality that prevails in
the jails that is of real concern the
county also pointed to their autopsy
which said Michael's cause of death was
cardiac arrest caused by prolonged
agitation and physical stress Watkins
argued that this wasn't brought on by
the altercation with deputies but by
something called excited delirium that
was a defense that was used by our
attorneys I believe
or a medical diagnosis or a term that's
used to describe a series of symptoms
agitation extreme strength not feeling
any kind of pain things that might be
recognized that may cause somebody to
for lack of a better word can go out of
control it's a very strange
conglomeration of symptoms agitation
unusual strength erratic behavior but
most typically it's used by police
departments and then by city attorneys
and district attorneys defending against
charges of excessive force the aqua out
that excited delirium is a dubious
disorder at best it's not recognized by
the american psychiatric or american
medical associations they tasered him
nine times every reputable organization
that has looked at taser use has cited
concerns with multiple repeated
applications of a Taser depending on how
they're used who they're used against
how often they're used they can become
deadly weapons I'm not aware that tasers
are considered deadly weapons the policy
has changed they're now a defensive tool
the deputies may not have been aware of
how many times mr. lass was actually
tased but the whole idea was to get him
under control or to get him so that we
could actually control him better he's
under protective custody Michaels and
protective custody is in the county jail
the deputies are supposed to be
protecting him
not killing him in fall 2010 after a
three week trial the jury decided that
excessive force was not used and the
county and deputies were not liable for
Michael's death the deputies did when
they took the law into their own hands
and killed them literally killed him a
second independent autopsy commissioned
by Frederick glass was seen by jurors
during the trial the results were
strikingly different from the autopsy
commissioned by the county in the
county's version Michael's death was an
accident caused by cardiac arrest in the
independent version Michael's suffered a
broken neck and died of a homicide
you never you never get over it I call
him my son I call him my might my child
my kid he was 27 years old he's always
your kid no matter how old he is and you
took that away from me
[Music]
I can't sleep that night I very rarely
sleep good at night and lay up there
every single night thinking about it I
used to get my car and try to go to work
and I couldn't go to work knowing what
they had done to my son
[Music]